[Music]
so thanks everyone for coming to this
panel we're to talk about social media
marketing today and we have a pretty
good group of people here to talk as
well my name is Mike Arrington I'm the
founder of a blog called TechCrunch from
Stanford Law School 95 although all my
friends and roommates were business
students because you guys were a lot
cooler than the law students I like
coming back here as often as I can and
speaking and seeing all the companies
that you guys tend to start how many
people here are actually students or
former students at Stanford so everybody
almost okay great no what do you do but
you didn't go to Stanford did you have
Berkeley so we have a bit of time here
and a big part of this would be audience
participation I especially want to hear
about those of you who have your own
companies and thought about these issues
and how you've dealt with them I'd like
the panel to introduce each person
introduce themselves Clara on the end it
also wrote a book and we're going to
talk about the book quite a bit and I
got one copy but there's one more copy
and the other copy is going to go to
person s it length yes yeah no lame you
can share mine but or you could buy one
yourself but whoever had asked the best
question sort of the best conversational
topic at the end has decided by Clara
and me so yeah if we don't it'll be
interesting so yes bo7 Giulio Julia yeah
Julia
actually original Brazilian says
Portuguese rather than Spanish that's
the difference but JSP o7 work at
experience project for those of you not
familiar with the site we are a
community where people share the life
experiences that matter the most of them
and through that portfolio of
experiences an interest meet other
people that are similar to them and are
able to form connections with new people
that that they may that they may have
wanted to meet but maybe never had the
opportunity to meet we've been around
for about two and a half years now I
joined the company
a couple months into it sort of as the
first token business guy responsible for
you know marketing business development
a lot of the product work a lot of the
operations and definitely have a lot of
experience using social media for
driving traffic users as well as just
engaging our users and making them come
back
Adam Jabbar I'm CEO of tap 11 we're a
new service it provides real-time
business intelligence for major
enterprises and marketing companies
basically providing them the best
analytic and CRM tools to monitoring and
grow their audience on Twitter we'll be
launching in about two weeks with about
a hundred enterprise and major brands
going into a private trial my name's
Layne Becker I'm the founder and I don't
know what my title is this week of a
company called get satisfaction we build
customer service communities for brands
and companies basically the idea is you
take the best of online forums and the
best of sort of customer service
software trouble ticketing software you
put those together into an environment
where your customers can go ahead and
solve problems for each other
in a way that can actually be tied back
and integrated into your existing
customer service system so you can
actually get a sense of how well it's
working the degree to what your problems
were getting resolved the degree to
which people are sharing ideas with each
other that are valuable to your
organization and and that result is
happier customers and spending a lot
less money on customer service my name
is Clara Shai and Stanford oh for
undergrad CS and econ oh five Cs masters
and currently CEO and founder of hearsay
labs we develop Facebook Applications
for small businesses to sell to their
customers across social networks I'm
also the author of the Facebook era
which is being used at classes here and
a number of other schools so it's great
to be here and before that I worked at
Google and Salesforce and also developed
an early Facebook application called
face force that integrates Facebook with
Salesforce CRM you're going into the
second edition of it right yes when
April joy I thought I'd start by sharing
some data with you guys about TechCrunch
and where we get some of our traffic and
because part of what we're talking to
his traffic and part of what we're
talking about here is branding I think
I'm actually not even sure what P oh
it's September to February I just had
somebody pull this right before I left
of a we had 48 million visits on on one
of our sites and Google search traffic
sent 29% of that Twitter sent three
point two point eight three point two
eight percent of that dig was three
point one eight percent of that Facebook
was it was one point two million so it's
about two and two point seven five
percent it StumbleUpon eight hundred
thousand you see that combined we're up
in the sort of ten percent range a
little higher from major social media
sites and we've also found that these
users tend to be a lot more engaging
than Google so the ten percent that
comes from Twitter Facebook StumbleUpon
and Digg are far more valuable to us and
the 30 percent that come from Google
search and I think that's a big part of
why Google has launched buzz recently
not only is the total traffic starting
to get really high referring traffic and
starting to compete with Google search I
think that they also are concern that
social media tends to send very high
quality traffic around the internet what
do you guys think about this topic in
general and let me start off with one
question you can jump in the first thing
we're talking about and laying up you're
gonna have a lot of opinions on this the
first thing I think of when I start
thinking about building a presence on
Twitter and Facebook and everywhere and
get satisfaction it is brandy
centralization and sort of loss of
control of a place where my brand is
under my control how big of a problem is
that and how do people deal with it I
swear here yes I sort of feel like
that's a [ __ ] question I mean no no
I mean I read that I just because
because I don't think it's right I don't
hold on who in here has a brand that
they control this you know like they're
having their own company something like
that raise your hand okay now leave your
hand up if you feel like this is an
issue that you need to deal with like
giving just get satisfaction your brand
putting on facebook where you're not in
control the tools and things like that
so everybody keep their hand up so every
single person agree with me but I just
don't I well
but they're not up they're not up on the
panel um I just I don't I mean when you
look at the direction that the tools are
going they're not going in the direction
of giving more and more control to the
centralizing force they're all going in
the direction of giving more and more
control to the companies that they are
trying to get to invest in their
platforms right I mean what is Facebook
Fanpage except really an attempt to
basically turn over control of the
Facebook environment to the company that
wants to control its customers
experience in that environment I mean
I'm not saying they're turning it over
completely but if you look at the way
that they're selling that's how they're
making money exports I'm not saying it's
perfect I'm simply saying what parts of
it are good because they don't allow
data exports they don't know how
one-on-one communication they don't
allow much of anything well no that's
not necessarily when you buy a show you
send the ads pointing to that Facebook
page right so okay so in turn on the
question of data export right so get
satisfaction launching up I mean we're
basically launching a Facebook version
of get satisfaction four pages in the
next couple of weeks they're gonna kill
me for giving that away and book version
of just yeah so basically embedded in
your Facebook fan page you can take get
satisfaction and put it in there and you
know man my CEO is going to shoot me in
the face when I get back is that is that
flash or what are you just do it through
a deal with Facebook or what no it's
done via the API no it's built on top of
our API Facebook application so the
customers whatever I've done I've gone
into the pool so I'm so the point the
point is simply that data export is I
just think it's I think it's a more
complicated situation all right I think
there is I think that it is a difficult
situation right now but in order for
brands to be happy and brands the way
that people spend money inside Facebook
in order for those brands to be happy I
think there is just going to be more
negotiation over time so I just think
it's I think it's a [ __ ] question
because it's a it's just a negotiation
inside a new environment I mean there
are a lot of different environments in
which brands have to participate and
this is just another one of them all
right did the other panelists object to
the question as well
maybe a slightly different way to look
at it as well as trying to think about
as the brands start to have brand
ambassadors and for example Best Buy I
signed up 2,500 people to be volunteers
to speak on their behalf and I think
just I guess tides partly to your
question when you have 2,500 employees
responding to you know customer service
issues on one hand it's you know really
exciting you have all these different
people all communicating at the other
side then and that starts to beg the
question of having workflow tools and
having you know all the things that you
would want to be able to understand how
different people at an organization are
communicating especially because it's a
little bit different than I am or a
phone call and that whatever they say is
going to you know stick in that
real-time feed that's then searchable so
that you've reached the one other issue
which is everyone in your organization
is now a customer service rep and has an
opinion and speaking unofficially or
officially on behalf of the company I
want to dive into more that later
because I think it's a real issue for
companies now whether it's a challenge
or an opportunity however you choose to
look at it is that we operate in an
environment of transparency just like
the internet was a disruptive force and
all the sudden people could Google
prices and kind of do comparison
shopping social media Facebook Twitter
it's been extremely disruptive for how
companies operate both internally as
well as externally because it's a
completely new communications medium
where it's public or semi-public in many
cases and a lot of companies that
haven't had good communications in the
past both internally and externally now
have to completely change their business
processes and think about how they
respond how they listen and how they
react and adapt to this new environment
whenever there's a big change in terms
of what medium people are using for
communication they're the tools are
gonna have to adapt and the rules are
gonna have to adapt in the same way that
I would imagine when the internet first
came out and companies had webpages that
was a new thing they weren't used to in
terms of how they represented themselves
how they represented their brand now
people are using social media so you
know it's very challenging at first cuz
you got to figure out how to do it but
given that people are there and that's
what they're using to communicate you
need to have a presence there and you
seem to be to make sure that the way
that your brand translates to this new
communication tool reflects the message
you want to give
to your consumers so I think the
consensus is that you have to do this
lane thinks that it's actually
ridiculous to even question doing this
and and I know and I don't les I
disagree with them but I think some big
brands out there still way on the
sidelines and there are people who
absolutely don't want to touch Facebook
get satisfaction Twitter and other
things how do we talk to them and
convince them to do it so when I talk to
organizations like that I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this one what I I mean
if you dig into the question what I find
is it's less that they're afraid of
acting publicly communicating publicly I
mean they've even even the sort of the
most sort of a you know technophobic I
guess brands are still interested
starting to think about that I think
that it's a fear of Technology or is it
something else
is it a fear of losing I think it's I
think it's basically conversation but
they're being defensive about I mean
they most of these companies have spent
the last 15 years building up massive
CRM systems that are designed to control
the relationship with customers yeah
right and this is a piece of that that
is different not necessarily something
that can't be embedded into existing
European CRM structures it's just that
they have a defensive Crouch because
they've invested you know multi
gazillions of dollars into these systems
and they don't yet know how this new
piece fits so for me I think it's almost
just a process issue for these companies
how do they figure out how to fit that
in what's a good first step get
satisfaction although if I had to guess
I'd say whatever is coming out from
hearsay Labs is probably a pretty good
first step in that direction too we
can't say anything about that yet
I think it's guessing based on the book
title I appreciate it well a couple
things I mean to answer your question I
think we're seeing a lot of progress in
terms of companies realizing that they
need to be on these social networks two
years ago when I started writing the
book we did these interviews people
thought we were crazy and now unless
every company knows at least they have
the consciousness around the fact that
they should be there because 400 million
active users they have to be where their
customers are and increasingly their
customers are on social media so they
get that and then in terms of the first
step I mean the thing about social media
is that you're probably already on
social media before you're officially on
social media because people are talking
about you
and so using tools like
search.twitter.com
or Facebook lexicon before they shut
that down was a great way for companies
to gauge what was going on and not
really work in a vacuum say before I
designed my campaign before I create my
Facebook page I'm first going to see
what people are saying about me both
good or bad I'm gonna capitalize on the
good and then for the bad I'm either
gonna clarify and correct it if it's
factually incorrect or maybe it's an
opportunity first to actually improve or
develop a new product or feature that's
been missing and that people care enough
to just tell us that they really want
before you actually even create a
presence just that ability to monitor
you know at both the overall brand level
every specific you know product in terms
of competitors the tools that are out
there everything from you know radian6
the viral heat to some of the stuff
we'll be doing with tableau but all
these tools are there to help enable you
to actually see what those conversations
are and then I think brands can start to
think about how they start to join those
conversations but definitely at least
initially seen what people are saying I
think is a good first step I mean with
gifts get satisfaction you have a
situation where you have very public
conversations around customer service
and we've seen that on Twitter as well
with the Comcast guy who I dealt with
very early on who will you know somebody
says I hate Comcast which you know
everybody said that at one point and
then he'll directly address them and get
a van out there whatever and deal with
it is that a good thing are you seeing
I'd love to hear some anecdotes about
companies that have done well in using
using public customer service to push
their brand as a company that cares or
gets it and I'd love to hear a couple of
anecdotes about companies that you know
maybe a face planet you know and done
things the wrong way sure I mean just
speaking generally the companies that
are at the extremes are generally the
ones that do best right so we can look
at an extreme and say that's a Comcast
and AT&T are on one side with terrible
customer service no matter what they do
I mean terrible customer relations
largely because of the nature of their
business which is infrastructure where
the cost of customers is nothing
compared to the cost of I don't know
cable underneath well it also may be a
lack of competition that's fair enough
yes and and then on the other side you
got a company like Zappos right which is
building or Nordstrom's builds its
entire brand on top of that and so it's
willing to make sort of massive
infrastructure investments so you know
unsurprisingly well I'm surprised you
can't surprisingly they both of them
participate really publicly and openly
inside an environment like get
satisfaction so Comcast has a lot of
success in the public sphere because
basically anything they do is going to
make their situation better literally
anything right like that's that's you
talk to Frank the guy that really led
the charge at Comcast cares which is the
department that does that and he said
yeah they gave me carte blanche because
what am I gonna do make it worse and
similarly it's true similarly Zappos and
it's been very effective do be fair it's
been very effective for Comcast and
companies like to Ellen and then on the
other end of it you gotta I know you got
a company like Zappos where every new
channel is an opportunity for them to
interact with customers right online
I mean phone email online offline I mean
they will take they'll take all comers
when it comes to new channels for
communicating with their customers so
those are the ones that so who's done
something really funny either or really
good or really bad I mean there's gotta
be an anecdote I was talking to hallway
about hanayo about a story I heard last
night that I almost wrote about where
rep went off and started yelling at
somebody theoretically on get
satisfaction yeah I've seen anything
have you seen that where people just
start to lose it because the sheer
volume and negativity coming at them are
we seeing somebody just absolutely
handle a crisis well so I've seen let's
start with people handling crises well
actually I don't feel like I see that
many people lose it all that often maybe
because if that's your bent you're less
likely just to participate publicly
generally um I generally I mean you know
we generally see that the companies that
do best are the ones that weather cry
see I mean they just don't they don't
back down from their position and sort
of they don't give in to the ranting
essentially but they do they basically
just they say they're sorry and then
they take the time to figure out what it
is that the customer is actually saying
because buried inside here would be my
advice to anybody in this environment
buried inside every rant is a good point
buried somewhere underneath somebody's
crazy emotional state there is usually
something somewhere that set them off
if you understood that well enough you
could probably use as a way to better
your service ignorant seems to be the
underlying point of 90% of the rants
that I read on the Internet well you are
in a privileged position for that though
for most companies I think did you sell
me I'm not sure I think that in your
case you've got a real situation where
customer is unhappy about something
there's probably something that happened
there so so in the environment of
speaking about brands or companies
though that's usually the case you know
so we had I mean tide is really active
in its participation and get
satisfaction and they had they since
they opened their public and people
complain about what tied well they love
tied actually I mean that's the thing
they love because it means they're close
well they love tied it's I think it's
yes what's wrong with tactic like what
do you do your own laundry so um I think
I just can't imagine like he's going
discussions I'm raking out over time but
they but they do because I mean if you
look at it I mean like cleaning clothes
is very tied into a lot of individuals
identities right because it's tied to
the idea of particularly motherhood hen
home and you become invested in the
products that you care about so there
are people that are crazy invested in
Thai products and when tide launched our
site it will wind up this sort of or
when they sort of actively started
participating in our site it opened up
this series of conversations from people
who were very very angry about the tied
products that they have loved that got
discontinued right like that's where
their anger came from we love these
products and then you took them away
from us now there might have been really
really good business reasons oh I'm sure
there were I mean God knows they do
enough number crunching to understand
but still it turns out for this
passionate vocal minority right you know
that's valuable
so then tide has to answer the ask and I
think they're doing this right now
asking the question okay what do we do
about that we've learned something new
from our customers how do we respond in
this environment how do we change our
business practices so that we can you
know address this really powerful vocal
subset of customers that I think is
valuable interesting one is that I think
customer service has it's always been
done has been done fairly privately like
you would call someone up you talk to
them on the phone if the rep goes crazy
no one really gets exposure to that now
the risk of
making a mistake is so much bigger
because that stuff just gets blown way
out of the water and spread and everyone
gets to see it so everyone every single
one of those thousands of reps that used
to have on the phone before and they
control pretty tightly now is a public
mouthpiece for the company back to how
do you control the representatives of
the company so that's a huge challenge
that social media presents that I think
companies have to think about very
clearly in terms of before jumping in
I think someone like Comcast that maybe
only can go up that's fine but if you
have a brand that's actually very
well-respected and you actually have a
lot to lose like tied like tied let's
say that's actually a giant risk that
you're taking by opening up the
conversation to the whole world and you
know on top of that adding all these
viral channels that if anything goes
wrong you know that stuff is just gonna
really spread let's let's jump into this
you guys have touched on it twice now is
gonna push it to later but let's jump
into it so your company a more than one
employee everyone's a customer service
rep they have their own Twitter accounts
their own Facebook accounts they get it
they're impassioned about the part of
their own products but they're not
trained sort of everyone else that can
really ruin things but also it could be
like at the corporate level if you make
a decision or your approach is incorrect
that could actually backfire for you so
I think back to your case study of
someone that has gotten some flak lately
chase with that giving challenge that
they had recently on Facebook they
pulled out a bunch of causes that were
in the running and they got a lot of
flack for that because it was like hey
this wasn't transparent why did you pick
these guys out yeah and that was at a
corporate level people probably thought
this through
lots of meeting lots of legal and it
still went bad so that's just one
example a lot of the transparency piece
when you think about customer service on
say Twitter there are two things that
all of us can probably learn from what
Frank did at Comcast one is the power of
persona marketing I mean it's easy to
hate Comcast because it's this large
institution it's really hard to hate
Frank Eliason he's so nice he has
pictures of his kids up there and he
always gets back to you and so people
can rant and rave all they want but you
know that Frank is out there he's
rooting for you he's trying to get your
services fixed and back to be a human
being it's all about the humanization
especially if you're not a very sexy
company a large corporate entity
the second thing that I think they did
really well was I'm realizing that a lot
of the questions that come up in as in a
public sphere like on Twitter on
Facebook oftentimes it's not your
customer support reps who answer that
question it's you're really zealous fans
and it's your other customers who rise
up and say no this isn't the case or
yeah there was a huge storm in San
Francisco they sent vans out to fix it
because I saw it and so we're seeing a
lot of companies where their call center
volume is actually going down so there's
the real quantifiable cost savings in
going to social media because they're
outsourcing a lot of this customers give
actual verifiable data on that because
I'd be I'm I've never seen a study on
that at all I don't have like hard data
but I mean I was talking every good he's
he's contributing to the second edition
of my book and he was saying that
they've seen it's like sometimes people
just want to vent and one good Twitter
attack you feel better already even
though you know your cable still isn't
going to work right yeah yeah so what
about this issue of who and your who and
your company is a customer service rep
and if it's everyone how do you control
them and train them a really important
issue and probably there'll be no
perfect service that addresses it but
some of it has to do with workflow I
mean so we've talked to a number of
companies and one of the things we're
doing is actually setting very specific
parameters where someone can be a system
administrator they can be an editor they
can be an analyst they basically you can
set different people having the ability
of what type of conversations they have
and then you can also look as sort of a
system administrator and look trackback
those conversations so you can't
necessarily take back anything that's
been said before gonna start to see
who's having good conversations and part
of their no tools today yeah there are
no tree hard to administer these
accounts and like you know Twitter
there's just one there's one account
there's no there's one set of
credentials guys like you we're starting
to come out with tools that help people
or manage these accounts Facebook
Twitter etc but what about who gets to
say stuff right yeah um gets to respond
part of it but a lot of it is companies
need to hire people they trust and
people always talk about Tony Hsieh at
Zappos and how he actually encourages
everyone in the company to tweet and it
they do Twitter
as part of their new hire orientation
does that make sense for every company
especially if they're not a retailer and
you're not b2c probably not but at least
figure out you know spend some time
figuring out what the social media
guidelines are and just like companies
have policies around what you can and
cannot email both internally and
externally or what you can and cannot
log about I think natural extension is
figuring out how that policy applies to
Twitter and Facebook yeah that makes a
lot of sense and I think also in the
Comcast example they started with front
you know it typically starts with a
couple people that sort of kind of
embody or sort of you know create that
personal brand and then it makes sense
to sort of stage your way from there
into sort of the customer service team
you know since obviously that's a much
broader undertaking so here's what I
think about this not that you guys asked
but I think that we're seeing I think I
think I think we're seeing increasing
rate of employees sort of doing their
own thing usually an impassioned sort of
response but in a poorly executed manner
to somebody attacking their company an
example last night I posted a story
about MySpace where I was posting some
information that their lawyers were
trying very hard to keep off the
internet and their social media manager
who is actually a friend of mine said
well why don't we just start posting
your your personal information arrington
and and I know he's joking completely
joking but that is not what the myspace
community manager should say when you
think about it but it just puts in your
head like oh yeah I guess they could
start publishing our personal
information we saw Randi Zuckerberg do
this with a bouncer at a bar in New York
she was out late probably drinking and
Randi Zuckerberg is like the sweetest
person in the whole world but she just
put on Facebook oh they wouldn't let us
in this bar the bouncer wouldn't listen
this bar he's a jerk won't it be
interesting if their Facebook page
disappears tomorrow all right and they
actually apologized and that I mean
Prescott about that at TechCrunch but
the the point is that people make
mistakes right and and people say things
sometimes without thinking and sometimes
your best employees your most impatient
employees are going to say stupid things
like Randi Zuckerberg saying that and
and I think it's just my opinion but I
think we're actually Society can
eventually become more accepting of this
that it won't become a big deal that
Randi Zuckerberg said that because
unless an official statement that's been
reviewed by companies but out at some
point it's gonna have to start to accept
that people make mistakes and that kids
put drunk pictures of them smoking pot
up on Facebook when they're in college
and that doesn't mean they shouldn't be
an investment banker later and companies
you know their employees sometimes say
stupid things and that means you know
this isn't necessary news event you guys
disagree with that or well no I pretty
much firmly in agreement with you on
that one I just think that the sort of
the the the need with the need we have
to sort of figure out how to forget
things right we don't know how to forget
things anymore like we used to just
forget stuff because it would fall off
or we disappear but now it's all
archived and it's searchable and it's
all there on Google or it's all there on
Facebook underneath our name so we just
have to learn different ways for
managing or reacting or frankly
forgetting that something's without
turning into a sterile organization
because the worst thing that can happen
is you never say anything controversial
and every you know we go back to sort of
the press release world right you know I
don't want that to happen we want real
human voices saying real human things
right we see this thing on get
satisfaction all the time so we
encourage employees who use the system
to use their real photos right as their
avatars and use real names don't require
just encourage yeah we're inspired by
Yelp who suggests that and it's amazing
to see the connections that individuals
will draw again like you're tied is
another great example of this right like
the brand manager is on there and she's
tried to paying customers yeah yeah yeah
I could switch to a different one but
they just they're really in the
forefront of my mind of the cutting edge
of cleaning for me but uh I really
should have worn the t-shirt today um
but you know like again it's like it's a
bunch a sort of middle-aged housewives
who are really end of the idea that they
connect with Mandy the brand manager for
time that is meaningful to them they are
tied customers for life and you see that
across the board doesn't matter what
kind of company it's sort of you know
sort of the equivalent of feeling like
you're getting to speak to the CEO of a
company you know when the JetBlue CEO
shows up and he walks down the aisles so
it's the equivalent of being able to do
that with everybody inside this business
that matters to you yeah and when Mandy
has a bad day and she tells somebody to
go pound sand because they're mad that
tide discontinued some product that's
okay that's gonna have to be okay cuz
net-net the company's ahead yeah pretty
much you know I mean we did we
negotiated we helped to
negotiate with tides legal department
for six weeks figure out how to make
that okay well it may have been a big
revenue to you but they're getting their
six week deal one you get one per panel
alright so I at this point if you have a
question you want to add of the
conversation go but we have a lot of
time us so we'll sort of fold stuff in I
want to ask one more question then we'll
start going into that trolls people who
attack your company on Facebook and
Twitter and get satisfaction do we
embrace them or do we shun them what's
the best way to do that as a brand
what's the best thing to do as a brand
don't feed the troll I think that still
stands don't try to fix the situation if
there there's difference being and
people having a problem right like
there's someone that's it's a fun one
sometimes yeah I mean at the extremes
you can definitely make a distinction
between someone that's there for the
sole purpose of harassment right
intimidation that's I think that's a
pretty clear line and you just say hey
these this is not acceptable we're not
engaging in a conversation with these
people then there's people that might be
sort of an irate customer but you know
hey you know my calls keep getting
dropped by 18 t it's just like I dropped
this really important call I'm really
pissed off and I'm gonna take that out
publicly that's a that's an unhappy
customer like that's a customer you have
to address you know regardless of the
customers attitude that's a different
question right I don't think you have to
let's say stoop to that level but it's
still an unhappy customer that you have
to address we refer to those guys as
griefers as opposed to trolls you know
they just want to cause some grief
because they have been wronged but yeah
they are a customer and so you need to
figure out what the most appropriate way
is to respond and again I think it's
about kind of getting to the Nugget of
their issues and ignoring the emotional
content it must be painful for brands to
see these comments up there though right
and and they're not used to this sort of
their brand logo they're they're they're
clearly ever presence and there's
somebody with the most outrageous
comment you know they're gonna want to
delete that right yeah
the first time and then they delete it
and then suddenly they see it you know
that's an issue in and of itself and why
are you deleting stuff and so what do
you recommend I mean what's words that
gonna go what do you mean when we reckon
and they don't we recommend that they
respond there's week so we treat tolls
if they that they actually respond to
every they were that they were that they
try and we like to say respond but only
if there's no malice in your heart so
respond but only it's true respond but
only if you can respond to the content
of the message and the problem that the
person is having and not any of the
emotional swirl that surrounds it and if
you can't then like you know go take a
bath and see if you can do it a couple
hours later and that's where you guys
start to make money right is to get
control of that community and start
deleting stuff you need to pay you well
just moderation generally yes one of the
things that cost in our community but we
actually we really we really discourage
deletion well you have a bunch of other
tools that you can use before you delete
something so we have so like we've been
trying to figure out systemic ways to
solve some of these problems or
everything in our system called the
changelog and basically what that does
is it you can do all of this stuff
delete remove edit all that stuff but we
keep track of all the changes on
separate page called the change log so
any customer in order to preserve
transparency any customer can go there
and see here are the changes the company
made yeah there's obvious exceptions for
like you know that's a credit card
number but just how do we preserve that
kind of environment so the customers can
still feel like no isn't because 99% of
the time they're not moderating things
because they wanted to get rid of
something they're doing it because they
think it makes the experience better for
everybody obviously someone has to talk
about it but he did the opposite he did
the no transparency he actually went
from having comments on his website to
basically making it a QA and clearly the
conversation isn't just on Twitter of it
the conversation goes across all these
sites and I think you know he lost
sponsors as a result and I mean he may
have lost them anyway but he clearly by
I just fix the situation that what are
you gonna go on Kipp satisfaction and
have a conversation well I think that he
would have he would have diffused it a
little bit if he started talking about
it immediately the less he talked about
it the more that the buzz chamber just
started echoing so I think I guess the
point mean that's a huge example
relative to like a tide specific
complaint but it's the same thing which
is the more that you just let them go
out and just make noise they'll just
keep echoing until the point that you
actually address it and that was you
know I thought surprising that his team
didn't do anything
to that regard and of course you can't
delete tweets I'm only the person who
does the tweet can delete it and I think
that um I have a lot of faith in people
in that they're pretty smart and if they
see something written about you that
isn't accurate or send that statement
you're clearly not been spent much time
on the internet if you if you have faith
in people and think they're pretty smart
well I have faith in people's customers
so if you're cut if customers by and
large love your product and every so
often some griefer or troll comes along
and says something well not only I do I
think that other customers may say good
things too drying it out but maybe
they'll come to your defense and that's
a lot more credible than you being
defensive as a brand and say you know
that's not the case especially if it's
an opinion related tweet questions
[Music]
strategic or tactical okay Michael
brought up a good one which is 10% of
his traffic is now coming from Twitter
and social media channels if you go to
Twitter eventual here a number of brands
starting to say that they're
increasingly getting close to the amount
of traffic they get from Google SEO from
places like Twitter and a lot of its
links right if you look at all the big
guys they don't you know from the New
York Times on down they all put a link
after link and the good ones put up
interesting things so like Whole Foods
as an example doesn't just put up any
type of link they'll put up a link
that's too you know a tip of like what
could you know give you like you know
better helps and so they've actually
added good content and there's a lot of
tools that now allow you to track you
know how many people are clicking on
that link and you know basically the
same type of things that Google
Analytics does so I think actually while
we've been talking about engagement and
service which is what a lot of the big
companies want a lot of the smaller ones
when you talk to them think more about
how you drive you know awareness and
promotion two thoughts here one is
finding with social media that the lines
are blurring across the different
functions
it's not about stand-alone customer
service standalone marketing and
standalone sales it turns out if you
have really great customer service and
you're getting back to people and
there's a good conversation about your
products that that is actually a
marketing and has brand effect when
people visit your page and they realize
that there's dialogue and that you you
provide great service that's part of the
value that you provide us as a vendor
the other thought is you know just from
a b2b example that I profiled in the
book which I thought was really neat was
astir data systems which is Silicon
Valley startup started by Stanford PhD
students and early on they didn't have a
big sales team and they didn't know how
to get to get customers they didn't know
how to do prospecting and what they did
was they had every employee in the
company not just the handful of
salespeople but all the engineers the
admin everyone from the CEO down go on
LinkedIn and do a search on a database
admin because that was their target
profile of a customer now what they got
back was a list not only of database
admins but database admins that were
connected to these people either through
one or two degrees and turned that
especially in an enterprise sale it's
all about trust and all about who you
know and so they were able to either
through the direct connection in
relationship or asking for a referral
warm intro hidden to these accounts and
that's how they got they built up their
customer lists some of them really great
customers including MySpace and they've
just grown from there so I thought that
was a really great grassroots way of
using the people you know and the social
capital among the personal relationships
of your employees should you should you
hire a full-time person to manage a
brand on social networks as part of the
communications group as you get bigger
part of your marketing group is it the
CEOs job I think it really depends on
the company I mean our company for
example we sell the small business and
in many of these cases these are sole
proprietors who they do everything they
don't have a separate marketing person
much less a social media person so for
them it's just much much more about
incorporating this new skill thing what
about this audience startups you know
coming out of Stanford you know they're
gonna raise some money at what point do
they really need to think about this
it's a new it's a new idea I mean a few
years ago there was no such job so
do you think it's very important to have
someone who someone who is someone or
someone's in that role from the
beginning just because the you know the
moment you start making connections is
the moment that things start happening
for you and it's pretty much impossible
to predict how those connections will
become valuable and yet the actors are
making as many as you can is the way you
maximize how much of the CEOs time when
you're a three-person startup should be
spent on this so well I mean you know
you don't sleep you don't sleep in your
circle right yeah you just make it your
second job when you're not sleeping like
with the other hand yeah no but
seriously it's a 20% of your day is it I
don't know and then if you have to make
decisions and you can't hire someone
else you have to spend half of an
engineering headcount expense on hiring
you know there's a real opportunity cost
here so I think I mean that's a question
we deal with we don't have this person
at TechCrunch it's all of our writers
kind of do it at hawk and do we hire
somebody and it's it's an issue it's
like an opportunity cost issue for us I
think it's good for people to do it
themselves I mean especially in the
beginning at least to understand how it
works and to really listen to the
customer and a lot of companies we work
with they tried or that I profile on the
book they tried outsourcing their
Facebook page or Twitter page to an
agency and they found that that put too
much distance between them and their
consumer and so while they may have a
dedicated person or one person or a few
people focus on it they still are very
plugged in in terms of what's being said
and in terms of the strategy and overall
messaging that's going out and so I
think I mean as I think about my time as
a CEO of a two-person startup I do think
about social media and it's an important
channel for us and I basically take the
time that I would spend on PR my
marketing and I spend part of that time
thinking about our blogs or Twitter on
Facebook probably the most important
thing you can think about because the
same way we've been talking about big
brands understanding what their
customers think it's the exact same
thing as a small company I have a friend
who runs a quarter rate company it's
called quarter ends it does a horizontal
quarter as opposed to protocol which is
a story in itself but he said over the
last year he was mentioned seven
thousand times and that's the same
that's as big
his whole email distribution list so
finding out who those people are
connecting to them and having and this
is also a conversation you can't really
hire someone at the very beginning of
your business to talk about you I think
it's only as you get bigger and even if
you look at you know a couple T's legs
Apple is the CEO still is very actively
involved you're actively involved so I
think it becomes more of a support as
opposed to a replacement we think he
also you also reach a point where you
can actually try to put up a dollar
value to what this role would actually
bring to you so you have a lot of data
on how big social media is for you and
you have a sense of how valuable visitor
is help valuable subscribers so you can
start thinking about if I had someone
doing this role and they were able to
give us a ten percent lift on this how
much value would that be like we run
through this decision like almost on a
monthly basis when we're doing headcount
adjustments at our company we began with
basically just our CEO and myself doing
everything in social media because we
don't have the resources or we're not
big enough we don't have enough traffic
to justify someone but then you reach a
point where okay we have enough stuff
that we can actually justify headcount
for this so why don't we think about
everything that we're doing and how we
can split up some of those
responsibilities we're still let's say
corporate level announcement vision
level announcement really important
things that's still the CEOs job to
communicate and still to represent that
but a lot of the sort of everyday
transactional thing and a lot of the
heavy lifting you can get someone that's
younger that you can train you know
train sort of working very closely with
you so they understand the right tone
and the right messaging that has to take
place and then I think that person you
know really pays for themselves as you
grow all right another question
okay can I start answering that because
we're building you guys mine completely
off-topic but you sass through the video
we're moving into video TechCrunch and
and we are so we're building a high-def
studio in our office actually
today the Carpenter was there and it's a
20 by 30 room and we're going to spend
around twenty five thousand dollars on
this on hardware and carpentry and
everything else the studio we're
building you couldn't build ten years
ago period I mean let alone for any
amount of money just where you can sort
of just jump on the air at any time and
start live streaming in HD so it's not
directly related to what you're saying
but video is hugely important and it's
becoming more and more important to us
as we go and just because the costs are
dropping like to nothing where you can
really do really really high quality
stuff and you have a Mac with Final Cut
Pro may or may not pay for Final Cut Pro
and you've got a you know a studio that
that twenty five thousand dollars is a
big line item for start-up you know when
you're talking about the same technology
of millions dollars even you know it's
less so anyway it's very important for
us we're gonna do a lot more of it so
but back to the question this is
actually question
I don't want to tell anyone but we're
launching a new widget on Facebook I
hope it doesn't get out I mean as you
said you have to think about this
question the same way that you think
about any marketing channel right like
depending on who you're trying to reach
you're trying to figure out whether that
channel is something that they use so if
you're trying to reach someone that
doesn't watch videos or doesn't really
isn't a big isn't overly representative
video watching then it may not make that
much sense like we've had to go through
this decision a lot because we have used
viral videos to reach millions of people
we have used digs to dig to reach
millions of people but those are
different niches and you have to
understand who is watching viral videos
in our case it was like our pet
community right so like pets like
puppies great for viral video put a
puppy on a video you win right so that
we got to focus on on back on that kind
of content for viral videos on Digg
there's a different kind of audience
right it's maybe more humour so you're
gonna take your content that's more
humor related and you're going to try to
pitch it there rather than take my let's
say my deep health-related content and
try
showed us a viral video okay I think
we're done with the video question do
not go viral you know there's guys is if
ceedric you know ceedric
he's been around is he go here he's one
of the speakers here cause world using
he was here this point yes you know he
talks a lot about how important it is
for retail shops to get people in the
door and you know depending on the type
of store if you're 7-eleven it's like
80% of people who walk in out of that
might not be that high but it certainly
is high are gonna buy something actually
might be more like ninety five percent
and then it goes all the way down to
other shops I'm sure this is a thing so
you guys talk about it Stanford all the
time but you know there were other types
of shops but they're gonna pay a lot of
money to get people in the door if you
can verify it one of the problems we've
seen with with guys like Foursquare is
that it's really easy to check into
stuff by cheating by going anywhere near
it and if you provide incentive like a
free coffee at Starbucks then there's an
incentive to cheat and I think there's
some technology coming out that'll at
least get you in the door before you can
you know sort of check in but from our
from our point of view we're seeing a
lot of startups at least addressed this
space but what do you guys think about
it yeah absolutely I mean I am actually
working on a blog post on this that's
gonna go out next week but um I think
looped and Foursquare I've done a really
good job here for example looped
partnered with jack-in-the-box so that
if you're in the vicinity of a
jack-in-the-box restaurant you actually
get pushed to coupon to go into the
store and actually purchase something I
thought that was really neat and then a
lot of the established social web
players like Facebook and Twitter and
Yelp they're building in mobile features
too that take advantage of geolocation
and I'm I could probably know this
better than me but there's rumors about
Facebook looking into acquiring loped
yeah we wrote that story I wrote that
sir than I um I think Facebook's me
everything I've heard is that there's
concerns with people when they I've
heard this is this
just whatever but in Korea and
specifically a lot of people have you
know like to share their location datum
via mobile devices and there have been
repeated instances and it's always the
husband was a boyfriend something with
the girlfriend of the wife but we're
like either they're tracking them or
they're demanding that they be tracked
and that and and Facebook has shied away
from this and I think at least part of
it has to be like you got to get this
right I mean the Attorney General's will
jump on this so fast as soon as you have
us somebody get hurt I haven't heard of
anything going on with Foursquare and
Gowalla but that's sort of the the
elephant in the room when it comes to
this mobile stuff which is the recent
site where they just checked people who
have checked out of being at home so
it's like four would be blur burglars
that would be a great target for you
yeah it's just sort of highlights the
absurdity of how much data we share
voluntarily on the internet and how and
how much that can hurt us that's a whole
other panel right there yeah right now
it's still relatively spam free I mean
the way that sort of email got to the
point where now we have to have these
spam filters and 95% of what I get every
day is spam
you know the carriers for all the bad
things they did some of the good things
that they like had rules and regulations
around sort of opt-in in terms of
getting that sms's and location will be
the same thing I don't want to get
paying you know with you know 50
notifications every time I Drive by a
Starbucks or a jack-in-the-box I want to
have some sort of role relevance you
relative to what I'm interested in and
that I think will be very useful in
terms of having things that are you know
the proximity actually becomes a new
search criteria and a new thing that
shows me things when I want another
question you guys have a say tied I'm in
a target tied could give me a coupon
Street it's true like I know yeah I
guess the one thing I would have to say
you're gonna let you know okay like I
like them but you're not engaging
they're just one of thousands of
customers I guess the one thing I would
say is I'm interested to see how so what
are the things we see with get
satisfaction right is that businesses
start to develop not a transactional
sense of their customers but a
relational sense of that customers and
by that I mean businesses of all sizes
even the smaller ones start to see or
even the bigger ones start to see that
there is a relationship value to
interactions with customers beyond
when they give them money right and that
there is something to the lifetime value
of the customer and each of these
interactions doesn't have to end with
some sort of exchange of money for goods
or services and I with mobile I think we
might know whenever I hear people
talking about like how we're gonna
monetize the mobile space they always go
straight to transactional coupons
discounts gaming and I wonder if there
maybe isn't something in the mobile
space that is also about relationships
whether it's a relationship between and
go back to that earlier thing about like
faces and avatar as a relationship
between you and one of the people that
works inside the company right or like
developing some sort of relationship
with an individual employee or if it
means developing relationships with
other people who also care about that
brand of that product or meeting up at
that space at a certain time so I think
there's opportunities in the mobile
space to think about it less terms
actually another question this side is
the interactive side no that's kind of
weird statistically that's impossible
but why is every question there's not a
hand up over here that's statistically
unlikely okay
Facebook users through the moon more
valuable than visitors from any other
service and we find that not just with
our own site Mike mentioned I mean if we
look at the stats of like people who
just the Google Analytics stats of
people who visit from Facebook they
stick around 10 20 times longer than
just about any other service possible
exception of StumbleUpon but I will also
say that when we talked to some of the
larger brands that we work with they
have a significant preference for
Facebook over everything else including
Twitter and I think a lot of that has to
do with Facebook taking the deep social
connections that people can create or
that are reflected in the Facebook
environment is part of it right like
Twitter you can get tons and tons of
followers but those are like connections
and also the extent to which Facebook
has made an effort to create a space for
an environment that's captivating for
brands and that invites them in and
invites them in to participate in ways
that line up with the way that they're
already used to thinking in mind in the
fact that Facebook owns our online
identity if you think about our Facebook
profile we're sharing more about
ourselves and we ever have before
you know where we're from how old we are
our religious preferences our political
preferences our job title I mean this is
a lot of information that we're sharing
because that's where our friends are and
their social pressures to share this but
what it means for business is is that
now there's a wealth of data that wasn't
previously available for us to use to
build better relationships whether it's
for recruiting or sales perspective and
to better target our messages in
marketing if you go to facebook.com
slash ads basically you can craft an ad
and target it to very specific profiles
of people based on the information that
they're sharing on their profile so I
think those combined create the
opportunities for these really deep
relationships not just between
individuals but also potentially between
companies and individuals you might
think initially that they'd want to have
sort of a create an update and publish
it everywhere and what they've also is
that they have very different
conversations on a Facebook versus a
Twitter that the Twitter tend to be
super fast it's kind of very quick and
kind of technically what you guys are
saying it's a deeper conversation on
face
and so they intentionally segment those
conversations and think about them very
differently yeah the other thing is I
think if you start to think about those
pages as landing pages like Facebook fan
pages as landing pages there's been some
interesting stuff on the web about this
recently
you just get a crazy amount of
information from Facebook about the
customers that are coming through and
that's you know I'm in Facebook of
course is going to charge for it
probably more and more over time but
still it's really valuable stuff
I don't not really familiar with the
first question so I answered the second
one in terms of social media
click-through I mean everyone knows that
it's pretty poor on Facebook and on
Twitter
because the intent isn't there it isn't
really a search a place where we do
search people are comparing that to
search result click-through rates which
are there's just nothing that can really
commit yeah I mean I actually need to
click the rates that we're hearing about
on Facebook are pretty good compared to
banner ad rates in general right but the
conversion rates after that may not be
super hot and you may end up being you
can see some guys getting pretty ROI
negative pretty quickly I think part of
the problem is there are a lot of
scamming things that are in there
competing the prices up as well you know
the KY stuff and the weight loss and the
dating and just I mean all that all the
stuff that makes up this the internet
that is such a wonderful place to hang
out in yeah that I feel really
optimistic about the future because
right now basically
because yeah because what because people
are smart and good and will always do
the right thing because Facebook has all
about who is looking at the at the ad
they know again all that information
that people share on their profile and
that they're tweeting about or updating
on their status message and google has
always been about what people are
searching on at that moment well as
Facebook adds more search functionality
this is part of why they acquired
FriendFeed you can imagine more commerce
and more search taking place on Facebook
but not only on Facebook with Facebook
Connect if you imagine implementing
Facebook Connect with Amazon or even
with Google or some sort of search site
then you could marry the to where you
have both the person's profile
information as well as a social graph of
what their friends are searching on what
they purchased plus the intent and so I
think when that happens we're gonna see
highly highly relevant ads which will be
you know right for the right person at
the right time pretty good answer I hope
so the only thing I'll say is you know
Dick Costolo I think Mike's conference
said that they had some really clever
stuff that was coming up I think there's
just a ton of room for clever invention
and reinvention of advertising in the
social space I think we barely gotten
started on that one a sense of it
there's a company called ad Lee
basically sponsored tweets like they pay
you to tweet something out to your
followers and you have a link usually
you can see how many people are clicking
on that link and get a sort of a rough
sense of what the click-through rates
are it's I can tell you right now the
variance is huge based on who is
tweeting that out and basically the
engagement level of their followers also
the other venema I would add to what
Claire said on Facebook is that there's
also a big difference when you advertise
something that exists within the
Facebook ecosystem versus running an ad
for something that's pointing outside of
Facebook so the former would be
something like I'm Zynga I want to you
know advertise farmville that's very
effective or I want to build up my my
fans on my page that's very effective so
things that I think keep people within
the Facebook ecosystem that's why do you
think about him a little bit differently
Facebook is convinced and you're
actually pitching this Facebook has
convinced people to spend money to run
ads to point to Facebook
right well that's why I want to buy
stock well sort of sort of right now
because I think it's there it's pointing
to Facebook but to something that you
sort of own on Facebook right like
you've got Zynga owns farmville and
they're the ones that are making money
you guys are drinking the kool-aid
aren't you I don't I mean I don't think
we own anything at all I mean Facebook
to us is is a traffic generation
mechanism we didn't get into this and
the questions I wanted to but I mean the
original stuff but I don't think of it
as my brand there I think of it as it is
an outpost to pull traffic into
TechCrunch I never want my brand maybe
I'm a Luddite here the way I'm thinking
about it but I never want my brand to be
owned by a company it has its own profit
motive sidered completely completely
disagree with you not my own sort of
business model so really if you look at
almost all the brands at least fifty to
sixty percent of what they post their
links I mean it may be conversation but
they're always putting something in
that's driving back and you know
Facebook has some of that but it's not
as much the culture I think to have you
know those links as part of the feeds I
think you're right it's your point Mike
I think you're in a very specific kind
of business where your business is
advertising and a lot of the things that
happen on you know we're in business and
news in the news but you you own that
media you need to own that experience
for a lot of companies especially we can
post our stuff on Facebook and we can't
put ads that way you can put ads up
against it so you know we just don't
really trust them to do that they're not
a neutral you know third party same with
satisfaction
I love the start-up we cover the startup
my friends have started but we don't
have an experience there because I will
go there kicking and screaming once I'm
there I know I'm there to stay yeah but
I don't want my experience to be there
because I don't want it there and I
think it's perfectly valid and you have
enough of a brand in a following where
it doesn't matter yeah but for a lot of
most businesses are really small and
especially back to your earlier question
they don't have a marketing firm right
so they got to think about advertising I
mean my answer to that was God don't
avert I mean don't spend money in
advertising you know engage in the
conversation drive freezers are so much
better and I know it's easy to say when
when for us where it gets so much
attention and bound that it's easy for
us to get we never spend money in
advertising but you know these these
guys they have to like it to buy users
to start of course they're going to have
to like give up their brand a little bit
on these third party platforms one of
the things that I still find amazing
all the record labels are still trying
to drive traffic to artist comms I don't
know how many years we have to go to see
that artists comms they've never been
that interesting the artists typically
don't put up a lot of original content
there's not a lot of value there and the
idea that you know these artists you
know that have you know great presences
on Twitter and Facebook that somehow
they need to be driving that to an
artist calm to build that site seems
kind of like an old concept now maybe if
they're driving them for a specific
promotion or to buy something makes a
lot of sense but building an artist calm
identity at this point doesn't make any
sense the artist is the artist brand and
they're just leveraging these different
sites to be so we should just give up
I'm if you're creating new brand you
might as well just create it on Twitter
on face I think it depends calm I think
a TechCrunch is enough you create
valuable content so you should be
driving someone there and then artists
calm 99 out of 100 of them never update
their content so like why send someone
to a site that's come to you than it is
for you to go to them and so for example
one of our customers he's an insurance
agent in Georgia so nobody goes his
website he's been paying someone a
hundred dollars every month for the last
five years yeah they do that yeah these
legacy guys to put up websites in the
nineties and can I get a charge twenty
exactly this guy's been getting gouged
and so we said look no one is going to
your website why don't you just focus on
your Facebook page for them I mean
obviously it's a very different business
than yours it's been great he's gotten a
lot of leads
he knows that insurance isn't sexy so
people aren't going to wake up every
morning and go to his website the way
that they would go to TechCrunch but
they're still able to engage when
there's a new insurance product or when
they see that someone gets engaged or
has a baby and they know that maybe
that's time to sell life insurance yeah
I mean okay I just you know we see every
day people like get their Facebook pages
deleted accidentally from a Terms of
Service or the guy Harmon there's this
guy I forgot his full name but he had
this he had facebook.com slash Harmon
the sales to him sold it to Harman
International and they just summarily
deleted his page now I got involved in
wrote a post we've reversed it all but I
mean we're not there for everyone and
and it's only funny the first time and
so it's it's you know you're really
giving up complete control to somebody
who doesn't really care that much about
you especially when you're a small brand
and you're never going to eat press if
they if they screw you
I'd be a little more concerned about it
than that you also can't back up your
information off of Facebook you know
they don't allow that information to go
off there are sites that are trying to
do that but you tend to get shut down
yeah another question right here I'll
see that you know with Facebook it
started to Facebook startling like Zynga
ville for a while until they shut down
the notification so you know what what
how do these how does Facebook stay
interesting and Twitter and you know
there's been some hiccups but they
realize that user growth and user
retention is their their top their
secret weapon in order to stay relevant
and so I think the opt-in nature of fan
pages is a huge one so if a fan or a fan
page starts sending you too many updates
or too many notifications will you just
stop Fanning or you'll hide it similarly
if someone starts spamming you it just
an individual sales person you can just
hide or block that person so I think
it's useful in that sense in terms of
being able to have privacy settings and
controls that let people with define
their own experience and opt in for the
brands and companies and people that
they actually like and then stay away
from everything else I think it's really
just a recognition that people want to
interact with both of these entities but
that despite what the Supreme Court says
people think about interacting with
people differently than they think about
interacting with organizations and
companies and particularly I think they
want to have a higher degree of can I'm
happy when something shows up
unexpectedly from somebody I haven't
seen from in a while I'm sometimes less
happy when something shows up from some
corporation that I don't feel much of a
personal connection to but if I'm
actively seeking out that kind of
information it's fantastically valuable
to have it so close and accessible it's
just a different way of thinking about
those interactions just making it a
bigger space with more entities
they got it wrong when they were
purchased by Fox and all of a sudden
they put up those ginormous ads across
their site I mean they turned off a lot
of users that was one of many things
that they did that you know started the
Facebook kind of wave of people going
there that obviously as you guys
mentioned that initially Facebook out
all those alerts and I think finally
taking all that stuff that you know
someone had you know bitten you by drag
all that stuff that started to become
extremely spammy I think taking the spam
out of the feed is super important from
the tools you mentioned to probably
increasing filters as we go along it
does start to feel like that maybe you
know a lot of this stuff gets started at
the college level and that Facebook is
starting to look a little bit like an
office park and you know there's a long
history of these these of social
networks eating themselves and Facebook
feels like it's gotten over that hump
but it always kind of feels that way
when it's and when when myspace was the
top site on the internet I don't think
many people were predicting it was going
to have its lunch eaten by an upstart
it'd be interesting to see if something
else becomes cool again we have time for
maybe two more questions Square
because words
there's difference between like ROI
positive versus like the best ROI like
it is ROI positive today like the reason
why you see all these ads on Facebook
like the belly fat ads except those
people are making a run til it's ROA
negative yes yeah I mean whether it's
Google is exactly the same I mean it's a
mirror I mean all this money going
through Google
I mean sure some of it's a Nordstrom's
there's you know all the same stuff on
Google and same thing people just run
the ads until their ROI negative what
the brand is doing so the fact that
Whole Foods has close to a million
followers on Twitter and every time they
post an update they have an opt-in list
of a million people that to me is hugely
ROI positive is that because they did
something right on Twitter or is that
because Whole Foods is special and
they've always managed their brand
appropriately except for that one thing
of the CEO I think it's both I think
yeah I mean no really why well they put
up valuable content I mean that I
mentioned that earlier that you know if
you look at the case example between
like Trader Joe's and themselves they
put up stuff that was more wrong I mean
where we not valuable content maybe
Whole Foods is just special maybe I want
to saying is it sometimes you know you
need to look at the product before you
look at the marketing and maybe the
product does a lot of the marketing for
you and so if you if if the insurance
company engages in the same level of you
know conversation I'm not sure they're
gonna have the same result right that
maybe work on your product first yep I
know I mean disagree if you I mean
there's clearly are things you can do on
the margin but sometimes it's just a
wonderful product as a wonderful product
right yeah I mean I think there are
examples it's still early and certainly
there's a lot of companies who are still
figuring it out but have you heard of
bonobos
it's a Stanford GSB company well the
first year they were in existence all
the only advertising that they did was
on Facebook and just from that they
generated a two million dollar run right
and they didn't I don't know the exact
numbers of how much they spent but it
was completely grassroots and it grew
through word-of-mouth and now they're
they're doing extremely well so I think
absolutely our case studies out there in
terms of success but is it as formulated
do we know what the science is as well
as we do for Adwords
certainly not you know how much they
spent on Facebook advertising in that
first time it's it's on the order of
like tens of thousands of course yeah
yeah they're both Stanford GSB r--'s
also we're mobile and some of the
location things we're talking about we
increasingly interested because you can
imagine that if as the location stuff at
mobile progresses you know a retailer
could run a campaign hey for the next
thirty minutes you know we're giving
thirty percent off you know a pair of
pants the first thirty people that are
and get it and you know Twitter is
talking about things like targeted
tweets that doesn't go don't go out to
everyone that only goes out to someone
in a location if you mix that you know
with kind of an offer that obviously
becomes very our way positive so I think
it comes back to as Michael said that
the product itself has to be good the
content has to be relevant and the way
you're engaging with them you can't just
put up a page and just assume something
will happen I think it dovetails back to
lanes earlier point where the first era
of online marketing was all about the
transaction it was how many clicks
what's the click-through rate what's the
conversion after they look at my landing
page that's important but because we
have the social graph now and the
ability to capture relationships with
customers we can take a longer-term view
and when we're calculating ROI and
calculating customer lifetime value it's
not just about their click-through rate
that time but across every time that
they're interacting with with your web
property use our Twitter or Facebook
start to come out KISSmetrics there's
another one called I'm forgetting it but
there's a lot of interesting ones that
are coming out that are trying to do
this how do we understand or the value
of a customer over time you know not
just what's the path that they did down
the conversion funnel but was it the
second the third of the eighth time that
they showed up you know and one of the
different ways that they've come through
and what was their exposure that they
got on other sites rather social
networks there's a much more holistic
view of that customer and all that's
really valuable still about driving
people down the funnel
especially
I think that's especially well-suited
the other use case where we've seen is a
lot of our customers are realtor's so
you're not gonna buy a home every year
at least most people are in this
environment but it's strongly a
word-of-mouth referral based business
and if you have a good experience buying
a home with with this agent you're
likely to recommend that to your
brothers and sisters and friends and
neighbors so we have we have five
minutes left
you can either end a little bit earlier
if somebody has one like killer question
that's really gonna win them that book
or comment so your hands up right now
means you've got something that the
audience is gonna really enjoy hearing
like afterwards highfive you on the way
out of here that should have been asked
at the very beginning of the panel yeah
that's it that's it that's a clear
question I think more than anything in I
think the fundamental principle of
marketing in terms of reaching people a
lot of people and targeting to them
hasn't changed I think it gets better
because of this data that people are
sharing about themselves what does
change is what I mentioned in my
previous response in terms of online
marketing shifting from being
transactionally focused to being
relationship focused that's just to me
it's see you can't think of it as
anything other than a conversation
anymore it is not one to one is not one
to many it's there
these people can tear you apart or they
can carry your message but I mean I'll
go out California here for a second and
say that I love that the the net result
of that is that people get to act more
human in environments in which they are
transacting I think that is something
that we have actually leached a lot of
our relationships with businesses over
the last 50 100 years is the human
element as we were working on efficiency
and now I think it's not so much about
efficiency although obviously that's a
component it's about effectiveness and
to me effectiveness actually means that
you need to establish a relationship
with someone
and that one of the ways to do that is
to expose yourself a little bit more as
a human being so we have this
interesting new world that's coming out
where we can interact with the employees
of companies that matter to us and and
that does mean everything from really
fantastic interactions to really crappy
ones they're interacting with us so we
better deal with it right yeah
and so there's a system that we get to
develop around that that to me at the
end of the day just means that we all
get to enjoy our lives a little bit more
we spend so much of it working so both
on the selling side as well as a buying
side I think having the human element
sorry to be like the rah-rah Terry
person on the panel but I really think
it's I mean even in my own interactions
and selling to our customers I do feel
like I've gotten to know prospect X and
prospect y better because I can see
pictures of their dog and they can see
pictures of mine
I like that all right final thoughts 30
seconds anything else to say then we're
getting out of here
I guess what I would I would leave
everyone where things please buy my book
now who won the book by the way I don't
know who do you think this is your book
you got it I mean I thought I forget who
asked what I knew this is gonna happen
I'm sorry I think I think I think
audience vote
no we can't we don't trying to do that
like know how to organize that I think
because he asked a question that we
should have been talking Bri one would
start with that and I agree okay
congratulations